Let us discuss the social rights in
Islam.
I have divided the social rights into
four subheadings.
The social rights of a daughter in
Islam, the social rights of a mother in
Islam,
the social right
of a wife in Islam, and the social
rights of the sister in Islam. I've
divided the social rights in Islam into
four subcategories.
First, we'll discuss the social rights
of a daughter in Islam.
Allah says in the glorious Quran surah
chapter number 81
verse number 8 and 9
when
the girl who buried alive when she's
questioned for what crime was she killed
this verse of the Quran indicates that
killing female infants is prohibited In
Islam,
not only killing female infants, killing
any infants is primary Islam. Allah says
in the Quran in surah Sarah chapter
number 17 verse number 31, kill not your
children for want of plea for it is
Allah that will give sustainance to you
and your children. For killing of
children is a major sin.
Allah repeats the message in surah anam
chapter number 6 verse number 151. Kill
not your children for a want of plea.
For it is Allah that will give
sustainance
to you.
Allah that will give sustainance to your
children and you.
That means in Islam not only killing of
female children, killing of all children
is primary in Islam.
And
if you analyze
before
the Quran was revealed in Arabia, it was
a common practice in Arabia that very
often when a female child was born, she
was buried alive. After
the Quran was revealed, alhamdulillah,
this evil practice has stopped.
But unfortunately, it yet continues in
the country where I come from that is
India.
And according to a documentary on BBC in
1990s,
there was a
interviewer by the name of Emily Beckin
in the program let her die.
And she says that every day in India
more than 3,000
fetuses are being aborted after they
identified that they are females. If you
multiply this figure by 365 more than a
million fetuses are being aborted after
they identified that they're females.
And it said that this is more common in
Tamil Nadu and Rajasthan. And according
to a government report of Tamil Nadu,
out of 10 female children born, four are
put to death. 40% of the female children
in Tamil Nadu after they are born in a
government hospital, they are put to
death.
According to the latest report of 2024,
more than 3 million fetuses in India
every year,
including
female children after they are born, are
put to death every year. 3 million
because of the Quran. This evil practice
has stopped in Arabia but is yet
continuing in many countries including
India. If you see the statistics of
India in 191
in that census the male to female ratio
was for every 1,000 male there were 972
females.
That means
approximately
3%
females or 2.8% 8% females were less.
In 1981,
for every,000 male, 934 females.
According to 1991 statistics, for
every,000 male,
females.
That means 7.3%
females less than male. From 28
to 7
7.3
it increased by more than double
in the span of 90 years.